trong hàng ngàn năm 1994, giân tập Việt Nam đã có chuyển thủ kinh tuần bất khóc trong công cuộc giữ nước và giữ nước.
Chào mặt đã đánh mại mào thế lực sâm lăng giữ bướng dành sân gấm bó.
Thế nhưng, đất nước lại tiếp tục giới vào hóc bất cuộc phong kiến suy tàn của thực dân để quốc tống chi.
Điên dần ta mất được lập, sống trong cạnh sử sức đồ hộ.
Nếu cuộc khởi nghĩa anh xuống nộ ra thử thức bà,
để lại nối đau và mất mắt trong lòng rất tổ.
Cách đầy chính mi nhằm nằm, giữa đèn tối nâu lệ ấy, khách hộ nập lập và tự gió đã trái mọng hơn mong giả hết,
thồi thúc rất tổ tiêm một con đường tướng nước đánh, ngày 1,5 nămu dình chính trong bà mời,
đàn cộng sản vệ đám ra đời.
Tự đầy, thích mạng vệ đám có ngọt kỳ rất lối.
Tháng 3 nămu dình chính trong bối mệt lâm, cả rất tập vụ nên dành trữ quyền,
khai xin nước vệ năm rất trùi cộng hoàn, mở ra cho rất tập ca một tiến nước mới độc lập tự gió.
Trong xuất bà mình năm khẳng, nít bà hồ thế hệ đánh á xuống,
mẫu xin ấy là nên những chiếc tháng văn dội năm châu chánh được vật cầu.
Tự vệ hứt bộ nămu dình chính trang hà mệt tư,
tự đầy đại thứng mộ sông nămu dình chính trang bệ người lòng,
thống nước nòn sông rất nước trọng diện của chiến tháng.
Năm một dình chính trang tảm bệ sấu rất đứt ca mắt đầu tốt cuộc gửi bối,
tự mụ cuộc ra bị chiến trang tảm phá,
địt năm đám vên lên hình nền chính tế năng đầu,
lời sống dình dân này cảnh kệ sắc.
Dịt năm hôm nay, ra đẹp đến đầy hấp dẫn của vật đẹp của tế,
ra hình anh một dân tập tiến cường sáng tháng vào đầy khách phọt.
Chúng mình nhằm giữ mọi người đàn,
rất tập tiến năm, ra đi từ tất phật nô lệ,
đến một thúc sáng đọc lập, tự gó qua mình hoa tích vật.
Hành trình ấy đàn tiếp tục với các học hùng cường,
sánh vai cùng với các cường của năm châu,
sẵn sàng nút vọt khi biết mới,
kiến nguyên sư dịch đất nước phổn với hải phúc.
Hành trình chỉ mình nhằm giữ mọi người đàn.
Khung trình được rí dấu trong sự sách,
mà còn được tán kiện xin đồng quan những cái ngàn,
hiện vật và tốt chuyện lịch sử.
Chỉnh làm chiến năm tờ đàn xói đường,
được tổ chức từ hành hành tháng tháng tháng,
đến ngày 1 năm tàn chiến năm hành hiểu khuôn trọng hành hành hành hành.
Là điểm đến thắp giấn,
để mọi người có thể cảm giận và hiểu xong hôm về chắc đường lịch sử vẻ văn.
Khiếp theo miệm tiên và khách phọt sửa từ đây,
hù nút thắt vọt, sây sử dất chứ phổn với hải phục.